all right here with the very latest
house oversight and reform committee
chairman James Comer is with us sir
thank you
if I'm wrong Congressman I've played
this tape many times didn't Joe Biden
say multiple times on the campaign trail
that not one time did he ever speak to
Hunter Biden or any family member about
the farm business dealings and didn't he
say a number of times that his family
never got a penny from China
Joe Biden said numerous times Sean that
his family never received a penny from
China we proved today that Joe Biden
lied during his presidential campaign in
2020 and he continues to lie today not
only did they take a penny Sean they
took over 10 million dollars and we're
still looking we still have many Bank
many more Banks to go and many more
llc's to siphon through but right now
the numbers up to 10 million dollars so
we proved that Joe Biden was dishonest
about his family receiving money from
China we also proved that the media has
not been reporting this correctly as you
could imagine Sean they said that none
of these transactions ever occurred
while Joe Biden was in public office we
just proved that was false as well most
of these shell companies were created
when Joe Biden was vice president and
when you got to the one million dollars
from Romania it was filtered and
laundered however you want to describe
it down to the bidens in 17 payments 16
of the 17 payments from the the corrupt
uh person in Romania the foreign
National Romania happened while Joe
Biden was vice president and visiting
Romania and in charge of things like
foreign aid for the Obama Administration
so the the level of public corruption
that we talked about today was
breathtaking in the fact that as you
mentioned Sean the mainstream media for
the most part didn't cover it at all and
said covered the George Santo stuff is
further proof that this media is is
covering for Joe Biden they are covering
for public corruption at the highest
levels in a manner we've never seen in
the history of our country right so
you're talking about 10 million dollars
from foreign countries uh even going to
grandchildren what services they
performed uh one could only guess if any
at all you found 20 llc's and you
describe the scenario where they're
passing money from one LLC or shell
company to the next to the next what
would be the purpose of that
well the purpose is to disguise who the
sender is and deceive the IRS so you
don't have to pay taxes on it so when
Joe Biden talks about tax sheets he he
doesn't need to look any further than
his uh Christmas photo I mean the way
these shell companies were created they
fit the definition of racketeering I
mean you you have shell companies that
were created for the sole purpose of
funneling money
to the Biden family if if the
president's son was was providing a
service to Romania or to China or to any
of these other countries that we're
going to disclose at a later time
well why didn't the country just send
the payment directly to Hunter Biden why
did they have to funnel it to an
associate's LLC and then to two or three
Biden llc's and then send the payments
uh sporadically down to Biden family
members like you mentioned the
grandchildren I hated to bring up the
fact that three grandchildren received
wires because I don't believe those
grandchildren did anything uh wrong they
just had the misfortune of having family
members who were using them in their
scheme to launder money to try to
deceive the IRS in order to not pay
taxes and to disguise who the senator
was to to to avoid getting in trouble
for dealing with foreign Nationals so
let me ask you it's really bad so you
sent a letter along with Chuck Grassley
to the FBI and the doj requesting a 1023
form after a whistleblower that you say
is credible alleges that the FBI the doj
or in possession it's not classified of
it and that it claimed that a detailed
quote your words not mine an alleged
criminal scheme involving then Vice
President Biden and a foreign National
relating to the exchange of money for
policy decisions now they said they will
work with you is that an acknowledgment
they didn't give it to you you gave them
a deadline of noon today is that an
acknowledgment of some kind that they
recognize that that document does exist
well they could have said the document
didn't exist or they could have said
that the document exists and we've
looked into it and there's nothing there
but what they sent us was a patronizing
letter saying that should basically
trust the FBI that if there was in fact
anything there they would they would
take care of it well I'm sorry Sean like
most conservatives in America I don't
have any Trust of the FBI and the fact
that the FBI refuses to work with us
when we're leading a very credible
investigation of public Corruption of
the president United States is very
disturbing Chuck Grassley is not a
conspiracy theorist he's not a drama
queen he has confidence in this
whistleblower I've read the transcript
from The Whistleblower okay what the
Whistleblower is a ledging Sean is
consistent with what we're seeing with
these shell companies and llc's there's
a pattern by the Biden family members to
launder money from foreign Nationals
in areas where Joe Biden has influenced
either as vice president or now as
president of the United States so this
is a very important piece of our
investigation and the FBI just basically
uh flipped it gave us the middle finger
and said you you just worry about your
stuff we'll worry about ours that's not
going to cut it we're going to continue
to demand to get this letter and we're
going to use every resource possible to
get this information and presented with
American pieces all right Congressman
James Coleman good work we'll have you
back off and this is only the beginning
of your investigation I think people
need to know this was the beginning
interim report thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else